did you adopt the kid from India that's
real why to be ladies I don't feel bad
for white orphans dude because if a
minority adopts you it's like that's
weird like if I adopted a white kid he'd
be like are you trying to this
little boy or hold this down but now
white people gotta not be racist all the
time so they have to go International
with a doctor it's like car shopping you
got to get like a Japanese or Korean or
something
where's your son why isn't he allowed to
be here studying I bet
good for you dude you did it what do you
want to do with his life
that's
that's nothing for her husband she
didn't change religions but she Indian
enough I like this one
online
G's up dude yo you know how much hope
you give to Indian dudes they could
actually marry a white girl every white
woman in here got these 15 Facebook
message from an Indian dude like I would
marry you and you actually pull it off
dude you've given a lot of Hope to a lot
of creeps out there